TO THE POSTSEASO L L
OFF THE STICK OF LINE HOLTBY, Í.
IN LINDELL.
WA
NO PETTERS
LIS FOR GRABS.
GL
HAN THE HARD AROUND AND SCORE.
MIL RAFE WITH 9.7 SECONDS
IN
TH HAD TO BE.E. LEAGUE
GO.
AND YOUR FIR MARINO. THERE AND
ST AS THE PUCK FROM
McE STIF MARINO RAMA.
IT TO OUT THERE TO
SK
E THE BODY BE, MAYBE TO
.
ALR RADULOV.
THE SHOT,
WRR K K STICK.
HEN THEN, SHIFTY MOVE DOWN
THE START. GUENTZEL.
CA
AND GO.GERO IN FRONT.
WIS IT AROD GAMES.
AN OPENING.
POT SCREEN.
GRT POSIT THERE I MOVING. SAVE Y
MA POSSESS QUICK UP FOR
BL TWO-ON-E FOR WHISTLE.
LI CYCLE.
HE THE SHOT.
PA FRONT OF F  PAVELSK
CYG WITH H H BODIES YOU COU
NO HOPE TODAY BETTER
BE
E STARS' CAPTAIN, PETERSON
HE GRAIN.
GO
YOU CALLED THE MOVE. FAKAK
TO IT
SH IN ON GOAL TO
COT ONN PAVELSKI 37% IN
HIS LONGECADE
PL.
DID.
CARTER.
AGT HOLYBY HERER
TO DALLAS STARS TO GET THE
VIY AS THEY WRAP YOU HAVE